thalie et franck ne décolère pas comme
tous les plaisanciers du port de saint
florentin ce couple de parisiens en
vacances dans l'yonne ne peut plus
naviguer sur le canal de bourgogne
ils sont bloqués ici sur leurs bateaux
pour nous la conséquence c'est que nos
vacances sont interrompues on avait
prévu de naviguer on a dû revenir le
plus vite possible avec ce qui veut dire
lentement avec un bateau et pour revenir
au port et puis voilà on va faire du
vélo et les choses du même genre mais
nos projets sont interrompues leur
bateau va rester à quai jusqu'à la fin
du moins leurs vacances tombe un peu à
l'eau à une dizaine de kilomètres le
port de brienon sur armançon est lui
aussi touché ce loueur de bateaux
n'accueillera plus aucun touriste ici
cet été
la base a dû fermer pour le public pour
leur ception de bateaux de bateaux sont
allés à une autre base au dessus de
tonnerre c'est encore possible jusqu'à
dijon mais c'est la sécheresse le
creusot celle des gars l'ensemble de
l'activité du port de brienon est touché
pour le gérant du site
après la sécheresse de l'an dernier
c'est un nouveau coup dur les crimes
sont fermées de ce qui engendre beaucoup
de coups de problème pour les pour les
bateaux les clients qui devrait redire
sur breslau donc tous et toutes ces
personnes qui étaient prévus et ben ils
sont annulés
donc c'est un chiffre d'affaires en
chute libre depuis deux ans au vu des
conditions météo la navigation sur le
canal de bourgogne n'est pas prêt de
reprendre selon vnf
il faudrait même patienter jusqu'à
l'automne